mutation movie wastes the first 30
seconds making sure we understand what
mutants are imagine the carnage that
could've been avoided if only Oskar
Shindler had sold that ring and use the
money to save Erik Lehnsherr and I come
back to you
at the ton of the time Wolverine has a
skeleton made of adamantium this guy
punches Wolverine in the face numerous
times without breaking his hand and then
all the sudden every time Wolverine
punches and headbutts this dude we hear
a metallic Clank the TV was silent until
the story called for the characters to
hear what it was saying Wolverine has
the ability to smell others when they're
near but completely misses rogue
sneaking onto the car to the back of the
trailer yet he can totally hear some
bull movement on the trailer while the
car is on the road that makes him
instantly suspicious I saved your life
the producers of True Blood later saw
this and said yes this is exactly the
fake southern accent we want we're
arguing about Auto safety when the car
accident happens cliche so we find out
later that Sabretooth was here to kidnap
rogue but how does magneto know to send
Sabretooth here he doesn't have cerebro
to locate mutants Road was a stowaway on
Wolverines trailer Wolverine pretty much
drives place to place without any real
direction in fact the very idea that he
could find Rogan Canada at all is
amazing this is one of the best wild
guesses in the history of film now where
did these assholes come from
I guess magneto is supposed to be so
powerful that he could devote part of
his mind are constantly controlling
these desk toy clicky balls but even if
you could why would you say Burr to that
nines at the time nor the opportunity to
take these dog tags from Wolverine this
is Scott Summers also called Cyclops I
wonder how many times Patrick Stewart
accidentally called Cyclops Geordi
during the filming of this movie the
students are mostly Runaways frightened
alone and with ridiculous haircuts
assuming you can kidnap and impersonate
the pilot and the senator's aide is the
military not able to track where
senators helicopters go why is the girl
who kills people when she touches them
about to touch Logan the way magneto
creates this bridge is cool but it seems
a bit unsafe walking across the bridge
before it's even completed miss one tile
and you're dead why did Magneto's powers
turn senator Kelly into mr. fantastic
you shouldn't go how does mystique
impersonate a kid on the grounds of the
fucking school with super mind-reading
powers Professor X on campus I mean it
makes sense that he doesn't go poking
around in people's minds all day but he
can't detect when a new brain enters a
school why don't you just use it to find
Magneto
I've been trying but he seems to have
found some way to shield himself from it
yeah but I can't save you fine
Sabretooth todor mystique when they
wander around outside of Magneto's
fortress Sabretooth was just hanging out
in Canada with no metal helmet or
anything it would have been nice for
Xavier to use cerebro then because
Sabretooth went straight back to the
lair still on Cyclops find storm and
Cyclops take off and go to the vehicle
room leaving Wolverine behind but
somehow he already has Cyclops
motorcycle and has already left the
mansion before Cyclops realizes it
where's my motorcycle I wish I had that
cliche I suppose the professor can't
mind read the mystique is doing all this
could either right I mean these are the
same halls where he was playing around
and Logan the mind earlier why doesn't
saviours mind pick up a disturbance of
the force or something
Green is bad did the tiny frog mutant
just completely compress another human
being flat to the ground by jumping on
him actually go outside these things
what would you prefer yellow spandex ha
comic book inside joke mutant or not
it's a terrible idea to leave an entire
boarding school full of children
completely without adult supervision
sounds like a storms code oh really what
was your first clue Cyclops has no idea
what the substance is that towed traffic
on jeans face so how does he know what
sensitivity level to set his visor to in
order to destroy the mysterious
substance of unknown makeup but not
injure her face one of the most visible
landmarks in the world and no one
notices all this commotion at the Statue
of Liberty do you know what happens to a
toad when it's struck by lightning the
same thing that happens to everything
else I know she's a mutant but damn
that's all the blood that these three
super deep stab wounds are gonna produce
saber-tooth throws wolverine up in the
air and is somehow able to slow down his
momentum in mid-flight Jane use your
power try to steady him hang on to
something wait just a damn minute in the
previous scene when they were all
fighting in the gift shop Jean literally
used her powers to hover the enemy in
the air but now when they need to hover
up someone to the torch they have to use
storms wind and gene only providing
steadying support oh sure when Logan
touched rode he was knocked down cold
and woke up hours later in a bed but
when magneto does it he has full use of
his powers back in 30 seconds I need his
plan is to change all the world's
politicians into mutants so they won't
pass an anti-mutant law but it's pretty
hard to believe that everyone would
become a closet mutant after this or
that no one would report the strange
huge blue force field that crashed the
largest single gathering of world
leaders in history in one of the largest
cities of the world
no one else who watches this broadcast
notices senator Kelly's weird yellow
eyes doesn't it ever wake you in the
middle of the night the feeling that
someday they will pass that foolish law
seriously Magneto's worries are pretty
stupid it's pretty clear how that whole
humans versus mutants war would go if
they ever passed some dumb law
they'll down Dedham in the vault
mutation it is the key to our evolution
it has enabled us to evolve from a
single-celled organism into the dominant
species on the planet
this process is slow normally taking
thousands and thousands of years but
every few hundred millennia evolution
leaps forward
you